merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur henri guaino quand les
républicains
ma question s'adresse à madame le garde
des sceaux qui ne daignent plus venir
devant cette assemblée voulais lui dire
ceci rassurez vous je ne vais pas vous
parler de mon cas personnel
après tout un juge d'instruction qui
démontre affaire après affaire qu'il est
indigne d'exercer ses fonctions
cela se voit bien souvent après tout des
juges infâme qui rende un jugement
inique
cela n'est pas la première fois dans
l'histoire judiciaire et pas la dernière
sans doute mais quand ces comportements
deviennent habituel
il faut s'inquiéter pour nos libertés
enfin écoute un contrôle et les
perquisitions sans raison en violation
du secret de l'instruction du secret
professionnel des avocats
instrumentalisation de la presse
instruction à charge mise en examen
justifiable mépris de la constitution
mépris de la loi
mépris des victimes abus de pouvoir
voilà le visage d'une justice qui ne
mérite plus son nom l'indépendance de la
justice ne donne pas au juge le droit de
juger selon ses caprices ses préjugés
ses rancoeurs dans la magistrature comme
partout ailleurs il y a des gens qui
honorent leurs fonctions il ya aussi des
pervers des psychopathes des militants
aveuglés par leur idéologie des gens
auxquels l'ivresse de leur toute
puissance fait perdre tout discernement
qui sanctionne leur faute
quand eux qu'ils jugent tous les autres
ce juste même au sein d'un corps que
vous laissez ce que vous laissez
dévastée par le syndicalisme de
corporatisme en faisant de la
magistrature une clientèle
enfin circulez il n'ya rien à voir
circulez ya rien à voir
faites donc un recours en attendant
qu'ils réparent les vies brisées les
réputations détruites des innocents
traîné dans la boue
et pendant ce temps les trafiquants et
des voyous sont en liberté mais tout est
normal
l'état est condamné pour faute lourde à
cause d'une instruction conduite de
façon scandaleuse
le juge est promu tout est normal le
juge d'outreau est promu à la cour de
cassation tout est normal
l'institution judiciaire couvre la
fraude à la loi pour la pma et la gpa
tout est normal des juges politisés sont
prêts à devancer tous vos souhaits sans
que vous ayez le leur demander tout est
normal
des fous qui est un bide aux petits
pieds croyant siéger au tribunal
révolutionnaire
ce panier sera
la parole à monsieur le premier ministre
madame la présidente neuf des messieurs
les députés monsieur le député si
d'abord si christiane taubira n'est pas
dans cet hémicycle
c'est parce que les en guyane pour
enterrer une proche de sa famille et
c'est la raison pour laquelle les pas là
si noël vous aurais répondu avec la
conviction et la force que vous lui
coller c'est ensuite monsieur le député
moi je peux parfaitement comprendre vos
sentiments profonds mais en revanche ce
que je ne peux pas accepter c'est ici
dans cet hémicycle les mots que vous
avez utilisé et la mise en cause de la
magistrature
parce que si bien sûr monsieur guaino un
magistrat comme un haut fonctionnaire
comme un policier comme un responsable
public est responsable et bien sûr de
ses actes et vous avez d'ailleurs citer
ici une affaire qui a donné lieu à une
commission enquête président est animé
par deux parlementaires ici qui siègent
qui siégeait dans cette assemblée
mais précisément au nom même des valeurs
de la république qui sont par ailleurs
les vôtres au nom même de l'idée de la
séparation des pouvoirs le respect de
l'indépendance le respect des hommes et
les femmes qui font la magistrature la
mise en cause dans cet hémicycle par un
député comme vous avec la notoriété qui
est la vôtre c'est un affaiblissement de
l'état de droit
c'est un affaiblissement de la
république c'est un affaiblissement de
ses fondements
c'est un affaiblissement de ses valeurs
et parce que vous vous êtes attaché
précisément à ses valeurs
monsieur le député je vous en conjure
abandonné ce discours reprenez vos
esprits et revenez sereinement dans ce
qui est le cas de la république
c'est-à-dire le respect des pouvoirs
la parole